I love you I know
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
jingles oh hey Nick's been waiting for
that moment his entire life he was like
somebody did somebody say Iggy Azalea
like yeah he's like it's time I know a
song stop push here this ship ready go
he's a big ceej
can we go to the video of the guy that
time here the video maker happening so
high
and she wants to leave oh god bless you
didn't choke do you get it this be a
total nightmare
Oh wrapping in news Alabama reports in
freestyle live TV in freezes on the link
personally for us now write and tell us
what we're about to hear there's a
freestyle okay I'm just gonna pick it up
is there a style absolutely sit back go
ahead Marshall
okay years ago they tried it years ago
they tried it fully in it
did you want to try to read something
from your book yeah you can't blame him
they try to do it to him years ago they
tried done your free trial is over ten
dollars to do a spoken word for us now
write write and tell us what we're about
to hear you're just a freestyle okay I'm
just gonna pick it up writes down let me
sit back go ahead Marshall okay years
ago they tried it
years ago they tried
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you want to try to read something
from your book yeah dude see that didn't
happen to Nick that's what I'm saying
fast choke and Nick didn't choke that
guy had a tough time there's one part we
can hear we couldn't hear but he goes
this this is live do you remind you
first off let's go to the culture corner
what do you got video Nick you can't
blame him for not you can't blame him
not after what they tried to do those
years ago and what is that if that
happens in your culture cat what are you
doing what do you got what happened you
got a move to the next village over
can't be rabbit early in the movie just
not village sweating so bad are you do
your sweat sweat smells like soup some
kind of best con sort of oz you get out
yeah that's big reminder yeah
none it came with the fire they came
that he was bouncing and everything new
Texas mommy's like it's happening just
remember stay calm
[Music]